[Applause]
[Music]
all right
hello hello arizona
wow what support we have for our
president of the great united states
donald j
trump
it's so good to see you all here
that uh and i am dr kelly ward i am the
chairwoman of your
republican party that's right
it's an honor to work for you and with
you and we are still
hard at work i can see you're not asleep
at the wheel and neither are we
i can tell you uh arizona
is in play folks we are in play
[Applause]
when when i was watching
the election night returns and i saw
fox news inappropriately call
arizona for a radical leftist socialist
team i can tell you i started tweeting
out right away
to retract retract retract because
arizona is more than
set to be able to win
okay okay how about this i you know it's
not about fox it's about counting our
votes
[Applause]
count our votes and that's what exactly
what we're doing when
when when the race was inappropriately
called by the media
the fake news media um we
we you know trump was was just behind by
200 000 votes there were hundreds
and thousands of votes that were still
out hundreds of thousands of votes that
are still out and even still today
there are hundreds of thousands of votes
and i can tell you that it is trending
in the direction of president donald j
trump
[Applause]
we have the team on the ground we have
the people
we have the momentum we have the
the activist community that is not going
to allow
this race to be stolen from president
trump or from republicans all the way
down the ballot you can count on me
out on you i'm going to leave it at that
because you don't need to hear from me
you all know
i think we're going to win this state
for donald trump
[Music]
i've got some awesome people here with
me and you're going to hear from
from dave bosse in just one moment but i
do want to introduce
our congressman congressman paul gosar
we've got congresswoman w lesko
we've got ceo of the trump campaign jeff
dewitt
former treasurer we've got congressman
john chatting boris ed sting right here
so don't go away because we are winning
this
stay vigilant stay open do not let this
election be
stolen i won't i know you won't here's
dave
thank you all very much thank you so
much thank you kelly
this is an exciting day uh we are so
proud of each and every one of you uh my
name is david bosse
and i'm a senior advisor to the trump
campaign
and i'm happy to make i'm gonna make a
few thank you very much i'm going to
be happy to make a few remarks and then
we're all happy to take
questions uh when we're done uh first i
just want to say
that arizona's 11 electoral college
votes
are going to be in donald trump's column
when we get done with this
every legal ballot must be counted
we are here to protect every legal vote
if if the current trends continue
as we have seen because we follow the
science
president trump is going to overtake joe
biden if we are going to win
arizona look
what the news organizations that
prematurely called arizona
have really done a disservice to the
american people and so
look it's it it's that's water under the
bridge what we're going to do
what we're going to do is prove them
wrong okay that's what we're here to do
we're going to make sure that every
single vote counts and we're going to
prove
to the american people that arizona is
trump country
my next question is what does the margin
need to be
in order for them to retract this
horrible
horrible call that's a very important
question we must have the media
look after tonight the margin is going
to be much smaller
and so when they prematurely called it
it was a bigger number
but it was only 70 some odd percent in
it was an irresponsible thing to have
done
and we're here to protect the vote of
the arizona people
and and i got to tell you uh i see the
numbers i see what's going to happen
over the next several days what is going
on
um it's it's the it's the fake news
media
so so look um we
there was only about 73 in when they
called this race
so we're here to make sure every vote is
counted we're here to make sure that
arizona's delivered for president trump
for his re-election and it is going to
be
so i thank each and every one of you for
being here and i'm happy to take
[Applause]
questions
i i i didn't know of any such thing that
happened
[Music]
um
[Music]
do you think the calls in uh virginia
and several other states that were
clearly being for uh joe biden
uh they were putting up calls do you
think that it kind of showcases
the tilt
yeah that's a great question he asked
did did
the mainstream media calling some of
these states early have
impact on what happened in the rest of
the country and i think
the answer is very simply yes because if
you look
at what the mainstream media did with
the state of florida
we won the state of florida in 2016
president trump did by about 110 115 000
votes
he was up 400 000 votes and they called
california
before they called florida they didn't
call the state of ohio
look this is this is not a mistake folks
they have been against this president
they've been against your president from
the very first
minute four years ago so we are we are
tired of it
we're going to fight to the very end and
that's why donald trump's going to get
reelected
because every single one of you is here
to fight for him
i couldn't hear you
well all of the litigation strategies
completely are are currently being
thought about and contemplated
there's been no decisions on anything as
of yet
but absolutely all options are on the
table to protect
uh every single legal vote that has been
made
in arizona because when this is all said
and done
president trump is going to get
[Applause]
reelected
is
the answer is the answer to your
question is
yes um however this is way premature to
discuss those options because we're not
there yet
okay we're not there yet but president
trump is going to win
by when all the votes are counted we're
not going to have to worry about that
chairman of the maricopa county board of
supervisors who
supports this president said that he has
faith in the maricopa county elections
department
do you guys all agree with that faith in
this election department i have some
concerns about the election department
and about adrian fontes himself
he has regarded legal advice from
outside
and within his own organization and we
have had
our poll observers republican poland
observers
be disenfranchised they've been put into
a corner
they have to sit in their seat to verify
the signatures they were not able to see
the screens
that were in front of them they were
able to look at the back of the computer
screens
they were allowed to have to have
binoculars
but they could only see the name brand
of the computer
not the actual signatures of the voters
and that's just one instance
so i believe that one of the reasons
we're standing here is that we
want to assure the integrity of
elections in arizona and the republican
party of arizona and everyone
here will do we'll do just
that
so in michigan there was the 4am dropped
138 thousand
and 112 000 in michigan
referred to in his 2 a.m pressure are
those folks those 250
000 to zero votes provide are they going
to be
kicked out as fraudulent votes before
it's all over
yeah we're here talking about arizona
sir and i gotta tell you
there's a team in michigan doing exactly
what we're doing here so
i can assure you the people of michigan
are being well served by the trump team
[Applause]
now listen folks arizona the bottom line
is president trump is going to win
arizona i believe it
the trend is going that way i spoke to
the president yesterday morning
and i told him i believe that arizona
is going to go for president donald j
trump
and then he's going to pick up the other
states and he's going to win
[Applause]
america
[Music]
okay
you just asked that question and i
answered it i didn't
go ahead
our legal team is clearly looking at
those types of questions
it's been very well documented that
those are some concerns
by thousands of people in the state of
arizona
so they're not unfounded to the people
that it affected so
there's a there's a there's a process
for those people and
for our campaign to go through and
that's what we're we're
our team is currently looking at
obviously
yeah thank you thank you all very much
we're happy to take any more questions
after
after we're done here thank you thank
you all for coming
and we're willing to take some more
questions everybody here
from you all but the press conference is